and action
Harrison wants things to be real
it's gonna hurt but he's gonna do it
anyway
nobody's gonna believe it
is an essential element of what an
Indiana Jones film is
our goal was to do as much as we could
for real
[Music]
then
you're able to keep it real that feels
more visceral for the audience
Harrison still has that Brash in the
attitude get back
[Music]
there's so much action and spectacle in
this film but also it's got hard
[Music]
it's not just action for action's sake
you can see a human experience
I like the Hat by the way makes you look
at least two years younger
[Music]
I'm having more fun than I really should
so don't tell anybody
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thanks nice seeing you folks
foreign
[Music]